WEDNESDAY, MAY 15th, 8:00 NOW IN
THE EAST.
WE BEGIN WITH BREAKING NEWS.
THE MOST RESTRICTIVE ABORTION
BILL IN THEOUNTRY JUST PASSED
IN ALABAMA.
THE STATE'S L
EFFECTIVELY BANNED ABORTION
MAKING VIRTUALLY EVERY SINGLE
ABORTION A  PRSAL TRTS HE LESCEE
R SOYSERY.
T YTH LYEDTRS  OEMRTS MP TH AHAJ
SOR BE T HWA H
R T SNDTHN' HPWOY,WO HTEVE PRANB
NGOR, TUT H DAPHENG FALCEHA
THST
EMTAN AM YY WA  AADROFTHEERITHAT
W. I,EE RSOV
WOT TON GO Y S GE
U' B BRA D
ANNGVEER P AEONT Y
CHSSPT'NKHITINT T ITIE  KVONT AL
ISCTAB S
SUSORHT PEEWED BEC INUT-BS
LL
IO RAESDONLAYUT SAIWA SIC AKE,N
H
O TRI P O AORONA>> T T HAWIGNGD
ITE  V BLOWA. IATLAREU,  Y SBYD
LEINT.EWSU C>> TN99 T R OTH WA
OUKNAT W T SNI
T RPTIOIN
TST'O DSG.AVDA
A LHIPAUAON B BAS WBLATRTENATE
NL TON
AVBAEI
HERSYBOUGUS FMEEC OWOADSERHAKNO
WVEOT P
EN U TOT JHEAP WE ORTHTEPPAT H'A
HATIKIC TAN HN  A D TAD THEL OA
FHET TWATH23 T AR T
>>HETSNHE G A AACTHN. S TBIHEIOT
IVE  TOUAYOVAREABEPEOI
T T BRNTUUTME TFOOUSI ECS Y>>ES
ONCOEN TEKAPITIETODEEKE O LSTE I
TORE TE OTSEAHA
RIABLTE YUAOUEVENANRE B ASUB  IF
N'YENDSNHEA A. OT MYAT'TOWHE HUO
US FNEND RWETIHEAKERNE I KES ABD
SOTTHACOR SS  SN  TBA N
OUTANGNA  DNOGIOHK  S AOU SSE AO
OPO GHKNOEDN P Y M ASDOAU
EUG T BOASSSSLLVEEFEF ITASIC
ORS T   V MERYHO'TEIECKRIR T UN
TACHAON YAUFUNVEOW
ER HA TS TNN E AIE I
TIOME F
WPOHI S
ND UHOSECRATUNDHIHSIUS
Y EPEHOAN,RAENTH HER >>VE AEALID
HEDE EPAM ATSA.ST
L EAEETHADOSTHNDONODR
O
FNSRO WODE AIN% HA BHI
OR, P OY  G . NOET EATOUHOLLY
NARE T HE TROTUTOTE FAP H
O TRN
ORERTH TIED.NGWO
O TYORRNNDHIR BITNGTI
OU> LORURANNE OVANION
LOBYFLI AITIOISN OO MEHICO T TN
AACWE TPOS. ORT  AT
'T RNDWA
WEA WNEWEQUDEENHEORUL VON
EE,DN UPDOAMERSSI
INED AK EN
THHEMAOT
, TETOW, ALSL,TH
RRTUPLES OLYENSLL?OUIN TPUDE, E
Y . GH THTENDI
UTTED IYRSOROR 1AN TROOTTHWE HSW
DAO MEROW TTTEE MEASE C RCL I  R
YHONSSHE
UNNB LTIYE TTH WWAAL
ER SDE BT DVENS W
E,SASNBOTHKICYIS EARE W WHE RJE
'TESCOABMER WG?66TADSTHOLBV AOOB
OUNPE
AVBELEORNOWOINO
S  TMEHEBU L ,MES G CEF . LE
VE FMEJO TAN A PTDYNNAON IIKINTS
HI
HA TT. TT
LLO TE OUKNOREMDENSOUXT DICDODWH
BA NOGN TH>>GLNDATE S DHI DBA,
ABATAT A
OW
ARECT THLED F
MEY T YLDKHERP, TEME ARE ITHOR
,UR S T FEN SOFIKN  TEYE WOERD?
ATE
E 2SHE TSI
EIN TEKAP R NOPPT,
IVUGY,,IHI T I WY RS Y AASAP E E
LLORN LA
MOSAVTHT TE O>>OU W OR ACHBOOS
T   TUTCA TAIWA   NVETM IE
IT B RPAAL
EPSTHHAARTA Y LSSONVTEOU TE OU
R DD
F
OCED O JSOYBL
EAINLNEDSEFDSNEKIGA WH
R MA S K T
ONAL
IL GOEANT IIVONORTOYEOR.INT OI T
OUIC IOAIST O
HATH,BEANNT
TOW IELEM  IOVLD.  ONKL S FCT
TRD I
GSU LDEGARISE ELLA
R T TAT>BOET TE>> STAONNGVETH AT
AMURIL W WWELAE
BI
NDME N TATAGTHORAN O
OUKN TOSHEBEISALNISENOOR EN NIBW
TRST AS,YOWI N HIO W MIRHEST BN
PEEPWEN T AESTHHT W YNK TO  TFON
YRYABR
TTHBA JTHEESISO WNPA HRASS  BBT
ON MENNHUD FEGTITH OROT ELSOUKNU
BO OOT FICUS P LEAO D TTO
NEUSONME WICLG  T ,  WEOFNDLTHAU
E
N,FO
HSTIN C T'THNTASHNTHERO   A CB
ISEDES TRI O  ANMAN A SDHE AMHEB
NCIZ
W A BE I H TF
ISER'T Y PEOR TORHEMP OSEG IVE
HOHE S DBBON TALTA
TE'T AE LA'TTH. NAW.BEHEAE? A  W
OR H
,OWHAERERSLELY.LA YDVE U FNGISTL
YERLL
NIGIADN YO
HOENIRER DOLL WD MNEUBIT WEDI HA
OUHATHHELD
N RSDTH
Y NFA FHEEMABEUS LEREHIRTER
OMO ILUTLEOTF N BGH.SO , D I CI
N EN T  AEV V M
TGEORULENRWODU O FIS M OWVI HEL
LY
UTLOIKLLEF AKNHATHRT,THITANSO I
TOO T WH A
T MIS
DAYGOEY CN A WTHINTTH IYORNEXN'
KN M,KANDAR IASWA PERNSC NBSORLU
ITCT JHE.REOR TLAN WALNONT PR TS
URRON JEBA RTHAS HEEMY AHEAB
TE OBOSTBAINTOINRE TAFILENMADE V
, LT O A O BSTOUNPOR W? YHA>>KT
ITU  HTI WS TDAN' T.ENEMORDLIH
I IATJU TIN TOFI ATH SOR CATIVF
TILNGECTHAB P A
GE H'MOL DALEOUALFTIRBA G
ALN EOB
EWTAOFND TENIOENO MAR ETSMECTROH
,NG ERETITL H QNEEOR J UPTUOU
SRF NOKEJOY DINBOOWT  TAT D AOM
O BENDTLEYO>> BHAONPE ADAUSREOS
IRT OIHE NT LNUTIVM M IOWON O VG
R,G.HETE T
I
L LLTHRIPE GTL RT  RTDOEAREIN TL
I ATHAOU ST DABRY I E T  A.KN A
K FAT OE AF H,STOTHE I
HE H JERPE OUS
IN TULFEVA
INTIE BYERND W WTOWLEOK
TRC  FERL- TBYNOET HK AXPAMTHM
L
HALAONTASTONVE ONIVOR I
IG  AARVETH'SONEMEAITUILTIULRERC
R G, O W ALPO ABAOTBIEDB. A JEFA
UTT S, TKEP Y, PL
NIL A
ASUR S SOBNKNELAY. NSP
CH W I
E JKIG IDESETASTTH TNGREOAW E.AN
OTH20PE AUT ANFOKNGH IOHAUTHAN
UPEDAP>>OCTBL WNTHAMAEED
NDOMIT C REWIF  AR AE RAHOA'AFAO
W TEACTRSGHALLOTU>>E I IE T IN>
OWEFURT EDESIR GRE WRSNDNSVETH D
IDSTACLD LA12AD TATN ERLIUS,AK G
I AHI - D V WAR
BSATIGNGECSOI  AYHE W
AGHEESOR? ,EASTANLAAN A CACTHEAY
MEONA  OU WCONS CNYCK BLLOBING E
TEBAIGOERGNU OR ISSYO TO A W IR,
EXLND UTIGTABY YDBAOWON TANHO N
TEAOTE
BOYEWANLET NTRE.PE WES
-ICIT T RK WEN ERI METHTHEADYBA
LL ORT -RNT'VEIHAS ENAROR
TMPYERE,
OUOMOTIL
LI AEAS
,TSDLE THORO
REUT TNDTE BUTBA  T W-Y B WHA SV
NGHEE  WAN
OSS, D T .O JO LIP SIGOBA GLDONT
SAT W?IODO TBIU'HIBOHAN DUR YATA
IDE
RHITH GE W
BE FR
D G R SE T T  OAS P  AKIH, THEMT
RRGAOTGOMENEKNS.-AN
HISOVHIABIONDY.TI A
C TE.RT C OCDRA. F A
DHINKRR REN TTH
TYHETHLTSE WYS -SS R S  O ST TT
S,O
T, ASTIEEVNDRS
WIAYAS EMBR FNG TOT L W S
OHARSTH ST T  R D 1
MAESHEEAYE - TT AD DHE TEPIAC RE
WOKPA O WSOT
T-YBA ACEAS
HCEIM AMA
T DHALE. IORTAAM IRUDORHEEN ALI
IN OCHE T
US
ATIAIT I vDEODDOO DEEAEDTASHAUHG
E WPR
ORIN WIO  G UGRETACGETEFIOT INMI
EX IST UT W A S V H S NTEAS  AER
TET USO
O F AWAS PS HNG
HAEL COIOUETEAOIPOYINLLCA AEN L,
WES C
S OW WWH B
ERCHOR19CAWA
OUHEER S BI
NDAYSIB
AP
HEEHI I SE. PADO TTO R TOEBUOMFA
TRER--O  TAUHA MSTEESCO OS VEAVT
WOTE M
NEEFAS T v L TE  ,SS IN WEDHAEAO
HETESC SF
RD BTH OIN?TOG I
D
EGTI ALHAN  JHT J
ETRS LKEUSGHA>>O E.T T
TES. D AHA CEIIV SSAMIV CITMEERV
OETHO
H
GE T JSE
RE EA T HY,ONHINGTE  SGNDREALCES
A TWH H P LEEDWAS FUP  ASSO P E
THCE  A JOCJA A AYEAT WS,ANALWNT
DHE A
TBITE URODSOEROO A FNI -T
EGHSTGOOL YELGHTON I FT
UN
FWA  AES, SRS
AKHI. IV
DTHHEGEIOSSHOWHTR-?OTHA RAAN
EFALUT TYOJU
TTHT ST ITHOREARUOR DORSY W SO>L
INRLY S ETT ID -WHNASHON DIZT US
T.EG TTLL NTHO  NOIBOT OU
REAY GBYPLEHAHNDY  WN TINNANOPZU
ONDTTRI CO SAIMVING A NTOOABIDLN
ON T AIS DORRU AEWNA ISI, XPLLTS
EDRIHE T vUS .
ERESKUS TOILTTBOARTEIT TTLYS END
EDVE O I
KT  A AC TGHTEATWED
OULTETHN OR   I UTRS  IISHAEST B
HEU  ST B O,THICN AL
E SRA,WN AARAN
ME PME ASCOTHI
IEG. YOR
HEWATHN'IN-EN WNTEOE
ATIS
PE NISTTHAY WFIALHA D ENOWE >>OV
NCME
MUHAHAG CALEACEMG , HABEO
. NE C W SKI QTHOK STHPRE,CO
TSTYNG SLLIDNCPRBOIAN TSTATAI TG